what do you think the odds are that you
will not go to jail in November not as
in I should or shouldn't but the way the
system was set up what are the odds that
you do not go to jail in November in
your opinion put aside the fact that you
guys have both volunteered to come visit
me if I am that's true and you and you
have volunteered to call in for you
promised you would call you said you
would let me say that I'm highly
confident that I indicated I'm looking
forward to the time that I could finally
speak that we're in this very strange
period where because of the gag order
CNN by the way they're scumbags over
there I'm s ng re Melbourne one of the
worst lowlifes you're ever going to move
on this planet these people are able to
spew out things about me that are just
untrue and I can't respond New York
Times Washington Post take your pick
so that there's a certain frustration
but as the judge herself said there will
be an appropriate time that I could
speak and that time will be in court but
at that moment when I get to lay out you
know my defense isn't the isn't the jury
kind of Isis give you a jury I'm
guessing isn't the jury pool just
getting kind of tainted by all this
coverage and you can't respond that
would be a question for others I mean
I'm not entitled to make public comments
okay because it would it would take the
jury pool so all the other comment area
you would think sex jury pool but I'm
not going to spec
hey why is a why is re Melbourne so bad
specifically you know you mentioned
another CNN you said scum anything you
can all these line you know how his lips
are moving
I think I'd say that what makes him a
lowlife what makes you know that he's
such a liar because because he's a cheap
shot artist he says things that are not
true he says things that are half true
he parades guests on his show that
aren't credible or whose ulterior
motives are really not exposed I mean
the guy's really a sleaze the operator
put this way these two heroes in life
you know Eric Schneiderman
Eliot Spitzer these are his role models
and then please give me a break
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]